fashion was on the mind of eight Mendes
last night as I hung out with her at her
fashion show
[Music]
have your girls digested that you are a
fashion designer no I'm just mom to them
and I love it that way
like they never seen me get ready for
anything it's very important for me for
them to see me as just mom and I'm just
you know messy mom when I go out with
them I really don't put an emphasis on
how I look they're just so little I want
them to just feel like you know I'm just
mama you've done such a beautiful job of
focusing on them and is that the most
important job you will ever have is
raising those but last night the mom of
two was in boss mode launching her new
collection with New York and company
she's been with the brand for five years
Ava's date her four-legged co-star in a
short film for the line but she did tell
me about visiting longtime partner Ryan
Gosling on the set of his upcoming movie
first man in it he plays Neil Armstrong
he was in his astronaut gear at first
and then what was it like for your
daughters they loved it and they nothing
[ __ ] he's an astronaut so like daddy you
can go to the yeah exactly we're like we
haven't corrected them yeah you know Ava
hasn't worked in a minute her last film
was 2014's Lost River which was written
and directed by Ryan Gosling looks like
she just is enjoying spending family
time and I love that
[Music]